yeah so i am currently in texas but i
spent many years in the bay area and i
was really lucky to work with manish
agarwala at stanford and bjorn hartman
over at berkeley and so i'm happy to be
back even if it's virtually this time um
but today i'll talk about the work i've
done just for the past two years on
making videos accessible
[Music]
so today people use digital platforms to
communicate and increasingly we're
changing the way we're communicating
so video formats like explainer videos
how-to demonstrations and travel vlogs
are starting to replace their text
counterparts
and the scale of video production and
consumption today is massive so just on
youtube alone people watch one billion
hours a video per day and upload 730 000
hours of video every day
in addition it's not just viral videos
so in a survey asked 12 000 people to
name their main reason for watching
youtube videos
two of the top three reasons were
actually related to seeking information
they wanted to learn new things or to
dig in
into their interests
and of course youtube isn't even
counting all of the live video like zoom
or short videos uh like gifs and tick
tocks or videos we use for social
communication um like facetime for
instance
so there's a lot of ways that we can
choose to communicate information and
when we pick one like video some
audience members will benefit and others
might be left out so let's use video as
an example
so
video is great if you are going to watch
and listen to the video all the way
through so for instance if a doctor
sends me a physical therapy exercises
rather than a text description this
might be really useful um the video will
capture my intention and it might
provide this rich
spatial and temporal detail so i can see
how he's moving his shoulders
in addition it promotes recall so maybe
i'll actually do my physical therapy
exercise more often because i'll
remember it
but say you don't intend to watch a
video all the way through
instead maybe you missed uh you missed
this talk or another and you just want
to see one part of it
well referencing and reviewing a video
is quite difficult due to this partially
to this timeline based interface
and it's even worse if video is a core
part of your everyday work uh like for
researchers or film producers
so i spent my phd with manisha and bjorn
exploring how we can make videos useful
when people needed to use it for
reference or review
so in my postdoc i wondered about the
other part of this assumption what if
you're not actually able to see the
visual content or hear the audio content
even though you plan to consume the
entire video
so currently uh videos communicate
information both auditorially and
visually
and so some videos like
this genre of tasty videos that are
silent faking videos set to music would
be completely inaccessible if you didn't
have access to the visual content of
this in
the video
and this is really concerning as more
and more of our educational um and
training content for work is moving to
these video formats
and finally if you don't have the
appropriate background or even regional
knowledge there's other reasons it can
be difficult to understand the video
even if you plan to watch and listen to
it all the way through so for instance
if i'm a brand new uh crocheting i
perhaps shouldn't start with a more
advanced crochet video because it would
be difficult to interpret the visual
content
so media is most useful when it supports
the goals accessibility needs and
context of the users
and audience members actually might
require different representations of the
idea in order to best
get that information so for instance if
i'm watching and listening all the way
through video is great but also you
could imagine maybe more immersive
formats like ar and vr
in
in addition if i was going to reference
and review maybe a textbook or an online
article might provide me more structure
to
you to find text or to look through
chapters and sections
so there's this principle in the
universal design guidelines for learning
that you should provide multiple means
of representation
and there's not one means of media or
representation that's optimal for all
of course if you're an instructor and
you're trying to provide many forms of
the same idea you could imagine that
would be a lot of work
so my research is about creating systems
that make it way easier to create
communication that's more useful for
everyone and a key idea throughout my
work that you'll see in this
accessibility work as well is to try to
combine the benefits of multiple types
of representation so like text and uh
video for instance
so now i've motivated a little bit about
why i'm interested in video
um but i'll touch now on why video
accessibility is important so when i
think about accessibility i like to come
i've heard several arguments and i
here's some of my favorites so uh for
i think the first reasons i think about
are personal
so most people will experience a
disability either you have one today or
you will be lucky enough to live long
enough into the future that you'll have
one in the future
so it's in my own best interest to
consider accessibility now
in addition we can be personally
responsible for creating disability and
this might sound surprising um but a
really classic thought experiment that i
like is pretend that tomorrow everyone
sprouted wings and i was the only person
that didn't spray wings
this really wouldn't be a problem until
they moved like my favorite coffee shop
into the sky or all my friends start
hanging out there um so disability isn't
just about impairment or the activities
that you can't do but the ways that it
limits your participation um in
in activities so for instance hanging
out with my friends or visiting a coffee
shop
and so when we create media or new forms
like ar and vr intangibles it's really
important to think about who we are
lifting up in the sky and who we might
be uh leaving on the
ground and also i think there's more
people who experience disability that i
might have initially realized
so in america one in four people live
with a disability today and i'm going to
talk a lot about uh non-visual
accessibility in this talk so i'll
mention that a million americans are
blind and 11.4 million have another
visual impairment um and this isn't even
accounting for users who might not want
to look at their screen maybe they have
light sensitivity or they lost their
reading glasses yesterday
so how do we make videos accessible
currently
well to make videos accessible um
professionals
to people with visual impairments
professionals create audio descriptions
or narrations of the important visual
content that overl avoid overlapping the
audio content
and i will call out that this is
slightly different than closed captions
closed captions um transcribe the speech
and sound and make the audio accessible
for people for instance who are deaf or
hard of hearing
and all of this accessibility editing uh
takes place after the video has been
produced
so
just really quick let me show you an
example of an audio description if you
haven't seen one before this will go by
a little fast
so audio descriptions um the narrator
will talk first and the audio describer
will talk second
it takes a village to maintain and
operate a place like mount rainier
national park what role would you play
who will be the future of mount rainier
national park job titles appear
including trail crew archaeologist
engineer climbing ranger and more future
rangers children wear uniforms for
different park jobs linnea i'm a
future archaeologist
all right so i picked this one because
um it's one of the rare examples of
audio description that isn't for a film
or a tv show that's where they occur
most frequently but important things to
see here is that the author omitted a
lot of visual details like linnaeus
safety best and several of the job
titles and they also had to offset the
descriptions uh to make everything fit
within the time provided and so all of
this is really challenging especially
for film and movies where you have quick
dialogue that you kind of have to fit um
as much as you can about the visuals in
between
so the first project i worked on as part
of my postdoc was to see if there was a
way to make um audio descriptions easier
to create
and the first thing i wanted to do was
understand why audio description is why
audio descriptions are challenging to
create so i talked to seven audio
description professionals this included
producers audio engineers writers and
teachers to learn how they create audio
descriptions and two things key things
they mentioned is that timing is really
challenging there's always more that you
want to say about the visuals than time
you have to say it and also the wording
is important so
because of uh audio description happens
at the end of the video production
process there might be other
stakeholders like marketers or um the uh
the videos original scripter who care
about how the content is described
so to create audio descriptions
professionals uh outlined the following
steps
they identified gaps in the speech and
marked it on the timeline and they
typically transcribed via text where the
gaps were they didn't describe the
visual content in each gap
and then uh they would record the
descriptions of the visual content but
oftentimes they would overlap so there's
much more to say than time to say it and
then they have to spend a lot of time uh
editing the descriptions to fit and this
could take over 10 times the length of
the original video um and so this is a
really tedious process you've done the
creative part of describing the video
and then you have to edit it down
so the goal of this project was to let
people create
audio descriptions efficiently and the
key idea was to
basically do optimization to jointly
shorten the text and lengthen the source
audio to fit everything that we could
so i'll show you the tool we built
called rescribe
using rescribe you could insert an input
video
it would automatically visualize speech
and audio gaps along the timeline
and it would also
transcribe the video and show the gaps
in the transcript
so authors could easily navigate to the
gaps using either the timeline of the
transcript
so there an author jumped to a gap
and then the author can describe the
video by playing and pausing it so here
the author types get title gabby's guide
to ojai what's gotta be cooking um
rescribed and interactively updates the
timeline the transcript so that you get
a sense immediately of about how much
time you have left
and so then uh another description's a
bright a montage of bright footage from
ojai for instance
after you've scripted your descriptions
um then you need to record them one
really cool thing about rescribe is you
only need to record your descriptions
once um and the editing happens
automatically we used human recorded
descriptions because prior studies had
shown that blind and visually impaired
watchers preferred
human descriptions to automatic ones for
now
so
here's an example of someone recording
their descriptions
shots of lavender in a farmer's market
red flowers against a white house and
blue sky
and after you've recorded all of your
descriptions you can click create
and rescribe is going to automatically
shorten the descriptions and move them
around to fit in the time provided
and then you can go ahead and listen to
your results
title gabby's guide to ojai
a montage from ojai
shots in a farmers market red flowers
a courtyard and a pool
gabby bikes along a path
close up of french fries
gabby drinks sangria
gabby and thomas sit on a couch
hey guys
so
if you don't like any of your
descriptions you can edit them after the
fact or um lock them in place if you
don't want the algorithm to change them
so resky rendered three types of
descriptions it could render extended
inline descriptions so these pause the
audio to play back all of the
description of the video and this is
really disruptive to the flow but you
can fit as much information as you want
if you add a pause
next were inline descriptions so these
shortened the descriptions greatly to
fit them in the time provided so for
instance um a montage of from ojai was
automatically shortened from a montage
of bright footage from ojai and this is
what you just heard
so that changed the length of the
description and it also adjusted their
start time
but finally because we already had
this in an optimization algorithm we
kind of explored could we
actually extend the underlying source
audio to fit in uh more of the text
description
so in this case uh we are able to fit in
more text so shots uh we're able to
preserve shots of lavender at a farmers
market and we do this by extending the
underlying audio by finding um similar
beats so this one is going to break the
sync with the video visually but you can
also try to listen for the loop to see
if you can hear uh where we're repeating
the the music
gabby's guide to ojai
a montage from ojai
shots of lavender in a farmer's market
red flowers against a white house and
blue sky
a courtyard and a pool gabby bikes along
a path
close up of tater tots and french fries
gabby drinks sangria
gabby and thomas sit on a couch
[Music]
hey guys
so i'll cover a few of the algorithmic
methods that power rescribe so first
rescribe identifies the speech and
silence um in the video by first
transcribing it and then using a cnn uh
based detection to to find speech and
silence
uh next the author describes the video
and rescribe automatically aligns the
script and the record
and the recording and finally and this
is the core part of rescribe it
automatically edited the descriptions it
could shorten them delete them adjust
the timing or extend the underlying
audio
i'll just try i'll try to breathe uh
breeze through a little briefly on how
we did it but just to give you an idea
um for each description we generated a
bunch of candidates but of course only
one of these candidates can be included
in the final audio and we had about two
to three hundred to pick from
so we scored each candidate description
on a number of things so informativeness
was this description likely to be
important for the rest of the video uh
coherence is this likely to be
grammatically correct that's not exactly
what it is but sort of close so that
would catch things like gabby r back
which is not a great description we also
looked at edit quality so each time you
cut the audio that might impact
uh the final quality and finally the
placement so this is this going to
overlap with other speech or not
and we basically solve this uh using an
optimization algorithm
so we evaluated rescry with three user
groups so first we were curious uh about
could novice audio describers um create
descriptions more effectively we also
wondered if blind audience members would
prefer our inline and extended inline
descriptions to
uh the just pausing the video type and
we finally wanted to find out what
professional subscribers thought so
novice authors were able to author
descriptions in the same amount of time
that had far less um overlapping audio
instances which would make it quite
difficult to hear both the description
and the video
blind audience members really like the
extended inline descriptions uh and they
they liked uh the inline descriptions
because they were concise and used and
standard with what they're used to
hearing
on the other hand the extend extended
descriptions that pause the video were
really a last resort
one interesting thing to me was that
they mentioned they would like to watch
extended inline descriptions most of the
times when um they are alone so they
thought maybe if i'm watching with a
sighted audience member um it might
disrupt the visual content but in the
future you could imagine research that
makes those uh those visual pauses a
little bit uh less abrupt
and then finally our interviews with
professional describers were really
interesting so professionals were highly
suspect that ai could help do their job
which is quite hard um any easier and so
we found that they
liked that this preserve the creative
aspects of their work while shortening
the uh tedious part of the process they
had really great ideas for future
automation too so one thing that was
really repetitive about their job was
describing um
was for instance just describing the
same thing over and over again so if
they wanted a system to reapply their
existing descriptions in the future
so some takeaways from rescribe are that
it made it easier to create high quality
descriptions so instead of trying to
describe everything automatically we
used human descriptions and just sort of
changed them a little bit to fit them in
time
we also revealed a new type of audio
description that hadn't existed before
and was preferred by blind audience
members and users we found that users
had varying description needs uh based
on their context so the fact that
rescribe gave them three options allowed
them this ability to customize the
descriptions they were receiving
so
if we think about how we should make
videos accessible um you know rescribe
gave audience members sort of three
options that they could pick between
but
videos don't always have these nice
pauses in the video that can allow you
to insert this description
so one thing we worked on was
interactive audio descriptions
in videos where there's constant
speaking could we give the
blind user more access to description on
demand
so this project about uh about
presentation accessibility and we
focused on presentations because they're
speaking the whole time and also uh ocr
is pretty good at recognizing text so we
thought we could provide a good
experience
um so how peng led this project and
so just for an example think about
watching this ted talk without the video
when i gave up sugar for 30 days
day 31 looked like this
so if you're missing the visuals you
wouldn't see this large pile of candy
and the audience kind of gets the joke
before you do
so here's an example of watching the
same video um but with our tools so what
you're going to see here is the author
will uh sorry the the user so the the
blind user will pause the video when
they hear the reference to the slide and
then they will listen for the content
and then start playing the video again
when i gave up sugar for 30 days
day 31 looked like this
heading level 5 slide 11 undescribed
regions image a stack of chocolate
scattered on the floor
[Music]
so we found um so we wanted to provide
learners access so when especially when
people are describing their slides
they'll describe some of it and not all
of it so we wanted to provide blind
learners access immediately to the
content that wasn't described but also
access to that content within the
context of the entire slide so for
instance on this slide the speaker
described everything but attainable but
if the blind user just listened to the
word attainable it might be a little bit
confusing so we also put it in context
of the full slide which was extracted
automatically
so
so what we found also is that at first
um in some of our pilot uses people
didn't really uh try to query for more
information unless the presenter
referenced it uh so in this version of
the interface we also added uh these
slide transitions so if there was
undescribed content on a slide um the at
the end of the slide the system would
let the user know and they could
flexibly explore more so i'll show an
example of how this works
students should be able to accomplish
this learning and demonstrate it in the
way laid out in the outcome in the time
frame available
extra content on slide heading level
five slide six undescribed regions list
one item bullet attainable end of list
image arrow
so in that case the
the uh system let the user know that
there was undescribed regions on the
slide and the user was navigating i
realized i didn't mention screen readers
um but the the blind user was navigating
the video using the screen reader
and so when we compared this slideshow
interface that it that surfaced uh the
moments that were undescribed and when
we compared it to slides and video so
just the slides in the video side by
side what we found is that people spent
more time with the slides and video but
got the same
score on on a little quiz for both
we also found that using our system
people read less redundant content and
listen to the description closer to the
time it was mentioned so some users are
actually able to beat the rest of the
audience to hearing the joke
and then we found as i mentioned that
people were reactive rather than
proactive about getting more information
um unless there is an explicit queue
mentioned by the presenter so most
people just waited to hear if there was
undescribed content or not on a slide
and then they were they would uh listen
to hear more of the content
so from this project we learned that um
just extracting the content from slides
uh was already quite helpful for people
um and this is easy because uh ocr does
a really great job at detecting and
transcribing the text on on visual
slides
in addition we found it beneficial to
jointly analyze the audio and visual
content to identify these undescribed
regions that let people view a lot less
redundant content between the narration
that they're hearing and the slides that
they're reading
with their screen reader
and finally uh prompting people when
things weren't described so you know
they might not know that that word
attainable exists so letting people know
so that they can find it um let people
seek more information as
unless the presenter mentioned it they
might not know that there's more content
there
so both of these projects work with this
this constraint that
the video has already been authored and
published and there's nothing you can do
to it and it makes the problem a lot
harder than it necessarily needs to be
so in the next project we we broke this
assumption and we said hey what if we
try to encourage authors to make their
videos accessible from the start oh
and so in particular
we looked at presentations again and we
thought hey what if we could encourage
presenters to give narrations that were
actually more descriptive of the content
on the slides
so in this project called say it all we
encourage presenters to create embedded
descriptions or descriptions that are
present in the original video
so first we wanted um and this was
really inspired by uh our own experience
uh there's an accessibility conference
where people would ask authors to
describe their slides but perhaps they
would start with the best intentions and
then eventually forget um and so
and this is also you know our own
experience and you could remind an
author a couple times but it it would be
easy to just kind of go back into how
you're used to presenting the slides
without describing all of the visual
content
so before we got started we wanted to
know do people just incidentally already
describe their slides
so we analyzed a bunch of videos across
ted talks seminars and classes about
across a range of randomly sampled
academic disciplines um and and we did
this to maintain a a variety of kind of
preparation and production
levels
and in general the answer was no so 72
of all of the slide elements in our data
set were not fully described and one
thing that was surprising to me that was
that ted talks which are highly produced
were particularly good at describing the
text and particularly good bad at
describing the images and so what i
found out when i looked into this a
little bit further is that the ted talk
guidelines actually say that you should
keep your text simple and make sure it
matches your speech and on the other
hand they tell presenters explicitly
not to describe their images
because it might be seen as redundant
so a key idea i took away from this is
that when you're asking people to
describe the content on their slides the
design of the pres the design of the
slides as well as the narration matter
so uh
my next question was can we make people
describe their slides if they're not
doing it already
so we created a system called slideshow
it provides both real-time feedback and
post-presentation feedback and the idea
here is that we wanted to impact
people's narrations as well as the
design of those slides so i'll share a
quick example of the uh real-time
feedback provided by
this tool
and we imagine that the real-time
feedback could be used for more casual
presentations or in rehearsal as you're
trying to make your descriptions better
so here's an example
so today's section is organized around
two activities first we'll create a
colorful circle brush and you'll see the
squiggly line pictured on the right with
these rainbow circles
so in this example on the presenter view
it's highlighted in green on the content
that the presenter has already said
after the presenter is done um so
presenters can either use this or turn
it off but after they're done they can
look at the post presentation feedback
uh the post presentation feedback on
the right side basically shows
presenters what they described and
people can try to raise their score
pictured in green or red
to try to increase their coverage so
they could raise their score by deleting
excess text on the slide
by changing their script to add more of
the description of the content and so
they could get a higher coverage score
on their presentations
so
in studying this project we wanted to
know um could did this actually work if
we created these interfaces would people
change their behavior and describe more
of the slides so we studied we created a
study with people using their own slides
with and without both types of our
feedback
and what we found was yes so people
describe more of their slide uh elements
using sayadaw's real time feedback and
we looked at we looked at applying the
feedback both first and second so uh
would they see the feedback first or
would they see the feedback second what
i expected is that after seeing the
feedback they would do uh on the first
time they would do really great on the
second half so so i expected that um
seeing the feedback first would impact
that but in fact it did not uh which is
not a great sign for um guidelines alone
working well to encourage people uh to
give feedback on their slides
we also found that using the post
presentation interface people identify
3.3 times more accessibility
improvements with the presentation
interface as they did without it in
particular um we found some of our
presenters plan to make changes for
their upcoming talks so some of our tas
actually mentioned they plan to remove
excess text on their ta slides
we just
all right so
now that we've looked at how do we
create make a video accessible after
it's already edited and how do we make a
video accessible at the planning capture
phase
all of these
projects made the assumption that each
individual video needs to be accessible
but for this last project we're going to
go back to the beginning of the talk
when we're thinking about videos there's
actually tons and tons of them such that
for any one task uh you might need just
one video um to to serve your purpose
and you might not need every single
video to be accessible
so here we look at video search and
making it easier for blind and visually
impaired users to surface accessible
videos
so in this project um we looked
primarily at uh at search tasks so for
instance if you search for a video like
how to make chocolate chip cookies
you're going to get many um partially
equivalent results and same thing for
things like paper airplanes or
top 10 places to visit in italy there
might not be much distinguishing uh
which one you should pick
so in prior work where we just described
each inaccessible video in this video in
this work we're looking at can we
surface the videos or act that actually
happen to already be more accessible
than others
so if you're thinking about what makes a
video um more accessible than other
videos some things include perhaps it's
narrated the entire way through so
people on a how-to task have described
every step versus uh setting it to music
and so so we wanted to approach this
from a user's perspective so we asked 12
people with visual impairments who
regularly used youtube uh what they
found made a video more or less
accessible and what we found is that um
some of these we sort of expected so
just the presence of speech uh happening
throughout a large part of the video you
would guess that this video is more
accessible um but then things that
people mentioned that were a little
surprising was um so scene transitions
so if it's highly
if there's a lot of scene transitions
that prompts audio transitions like oh
you hear like a big crowd and then you
hear um you know a city street and
you're not sure what happened at those
transitions um so if a scene is very
visually complex it's likely to not be
as accessible
people also mentioned um undescribed
visual references so that's like if i
say hey look at this thing on my slide
you might wonder what thing on your
slide if you're not able to see the
visual content
so from these accessibility metrics that
we identified in these interviews
we also asked people to rate
a bunch of videos from one to seven um
on whether they thought the video was
accessible or not because it was blind
and visually impaired people rating
these videos uh it was basically the
perceived accessibility so what might
not be included in the score are unknown
unknowns or things people didn't know
were there
and so what we found is that uh five of
these attributes contributed to people's
perceptions of accessibility with
presence of speech being one of the most
predictive qualities
so after we had this accessibility score
and um these metrics we augmented each
video search results um with some
information about how accessible it was
likely to be
so we gave a summary um uh prediction
score so this one's somewhat accessible
and it provided some of the information
about how we got to that conclusion so
76 percent of the audio speech uh the
speech is descriptive but it has many
visual references about three per minute
uh etc
so we implemented this as a browser
extension so that you could go on
youtube and it would calculate these
metrics and actually show them to you in
the search results we found out that
using our tool people were able to do
video search tasks more efficiently so
before they would just trial and error a
bunch of videos until they found one
that was accessible um but with our tool
they were able to um
trial and error less videos before they
got to one they were interested in and
so now bruce the student who led this
project is looking at uh if these
findings actually play out in practice
so when people have this browser
extension installed for their everyday
use do we say do we see the same things
hold
so
this is um my work so far looking across
a bright a broad range of video
accessibility and i'll share some of my
takeaways from where i think this means
we should go next
so the one thing that surprised me is
that unlike
captions that just transcribe the audio
audio descriptions are quite difficult
because you're really summarizing all of
the visual content there's just too much
to describe in time
and so some things i found that were
particularly important uh were that you
needed to know not only what was
important to include in the summary but
also how and when you wanted to describe
it because that could impact the flow of
the video or it could have ruined a
surprise if you if you describe things
too early
in addition i learned that the the
overlap between the audio content and
the visual content is key so
as a person or a tool if if you are not
looking at both the audio and visual
content you might not know that some
things would be redundant if you were to
describe them
in the video
a third thing is that
what is important greatly depended on
the audience and their context so in
rescribe we heard about depending on the
other people that were watching with
them they might want a bit different
description but something i would call
out is that it didn't come up in um in
this presentation so far is that people
actually wanted very different things so
even for film and movies where where
audio description is more present people
did not agree on on what they would like
to like to hear in it so for instance i
met a sci-fi fan um and for sci-fi tv
there's basically really elaborate
costume design and setting design and
the audio description guidelines had
dictated that the costumes were rarely
described so in a show where the
costumes were really important um this
viewer was just totally missing out on
how costumes uh were changing over the
season and kind of what they meant in
terms of
the character's progression
so in the future i think it would be
really important to give people more
control over
what is included in their descriptions
and finally one way to do this might be
interactivity but it's a little tricky
so people uh
interactive descriptions can be really
great when you know you might be missing
something but for unknown unknowns so
when you don't know you're missing
something a good place to share those
changes might be when the visuals change
so for instance say i
said i thought that costumes were
important maybe the system would alert
me every time a costume changed so i
could optionally hear more about that
costume
and second i think it's really important
to con
to consider accessibility at every stage
so there's a lot of opportunity both in
video but in new media forums like ar
and vr to uh consider how the accessible
experience might appear at the end
and then finally um working on this
project there's tons of guidelines about
how to do audio descriptions for film
and media but very very few for user
generated
media because
um because audio descriptions are just
rare and
quite difficult to produce currently so
i think we need new guidelines
especially for user generated media
types like vlogs um or short videos like
gifs uh gifts that are one thing i did
get to work on and try a couple formats
for and that was really fun
also uh i think there's new
audio descriptions already static right
now but in the future there's new
interactive techniques that we can use
to make these more effective
so
this has been a part of my work um
building human ai systems and in the
case of doing accessibility research
i've used mostly ai and ml techniques
when i've had to do low level
interpretation or alignment so this
could be like recognize the text and i
have done used humans to do things that
required more context so imagine
creating the correct wording for
something might require uh you to have a
knowledge of where the original video
content came from
but one thing i've begun to question a
little bit is what is a really a
non-expert task uh one thing i found
throughout my work is that describing
visual content itself is actually uh
very challenging and requires a certain
background so um i think thinking about
like who is the best person to describe
uh content and some of these new user
generated media um is an important
question
so when i think about future work in the
space in general i hope to extend my
work to new types of media to make sure
we're staying ahead of the curve in
terms of what's accessible so this might
be ar vr 360 videos and robotics
um in terms of creating uh more
accessible content and formats uh i
think there's ways that we could improve
the accuracy and speed so you could
think of like social systems uh for
better labels um deployments and
creating data sets of like how people
edit their videos to learn more
and then i also want to support new
audiences and authors over time so these
are people with uh new goals new access
needs or new
contextual needs that i haven't yet
thought of
so i would like to conclude by thanking
all of my collaborators on the left side
are my co-authors on this video
accessibility work that you've heard
today and on the right side are some of
my collaborators on other projects on
video accessibility and natural language
processing that has really informed this
work
and with that i would like to thank you
all for coming to the talk and i am
happy to take any questions
hi um yeah thanks for the talk this was
super interesting
i guess the question i had as maybe i've
missed this is um
how much run time do audio descriptions
usually add
um in the terms of maybe like two
dynamics one is um you know he talks
about youtube a lot
and i i've personally seen that youtube
video run length has just
exploded you know it used to be
two minutes was the norm now you're
seeing like hours upon hours and i'm
wondering you know if
if these audio descriptions are adding
time or you know you're constantly
trying to splice uh descriptions between
speaking
how does that affect sort of the um
the listener in terms of like maybe
fatigue or actually you know you're
making the content more accessible but
at the same time it's a bit
i don't want to say like a drag to sort
of listen to but it's maybe like
a lot of just sort of content coming at
you non-stop
yes that's a great question um yeah
thank you so much for that question so
so a constraint of so i would say that
the place that we see audio description
the most right now isn't for uh like
films movies advertisements things with
higher production values and oftentimes
a constraint that those production teams
set is that you can't increase the run
times at all um so okay so you won't
hear yeah so you won't um they won't
increase the run times but they also
have to like have a really strict
summary of what's described and so on
some of these uh on on some of the
projects i've worked on
uh part of it's about like
how do we get the content that people
want to hear in as little time as
possible and um one
one thought is that so for the
for rescribe for instance that first
project it had the option to not
increase the runtime at all or if it did
increase the runtime it was only up to i
think like 1.25 times the original uh
video so it'd be
a bit longer but people could opt out of
that and just take the take the plane
run time um and then finally thing i
think what is important about your
question is
how does it impact the flow of the video
or how pleasant it is to listen to and i
would say that um i would encourage
anyone here to look up uh like lion king
audio description or um like uh i think
the incredibles audio description
there's there's a couple examples on
youtube they're really quite an art form
like the narrator has a voice that goes
along really well with the visual
content so um it ends up not being as
disruptive and i think it's sort of done
as an art to to minimize this disruption
but that's that's a great question
awesome thank you
great so uh
oh uh can can you hear me amy
yes yes okay great
um so um uh
thank you for the talk and um we have a
few more questions question about
customizability
yeah i was wondering if you noticed
difference in what people wanted
depending on whether they were
congenitally blind or whether they lost
their side where that showed up
uh that's such a good question it didn't
show up in our um
in this work necessarily but i i will
say that it's something that um showed
up in
uh so i did a project with uh cole
gleason on um making gifts accessible
and so so one thing that can happen is
that you're left out of uh sort of like
visual content over time so you might
not understand kind of like uh visual
uh
sort of like
visual shorthands so say i say uh
like an example is like um
a this
i'm having trouble with the finding
examples but but perhaps there's like a
common meme that maybe sighted people
will have seen before and could
recognize based on the description
um like an awkward penguin meme um so
for people who have been blind for more
time they might have
not had access to that cultural context
so so i have noticed something about
like the terms that you're describing
more or describing less
i think that would totally matter on how
much access you've had to that and that
could determine be determined on like
when uh you went blind yeah yeah thanks
yeah
great
hi um i didn't actually have a question
i don't know why i'm called but since
now that i'm being called i think i'll
just ask the question um um can you go
back to the slides where you talk about
like um
where you describe your like general
approach to like ai and like um human
how you delegate um
the tasks so like
yeah i thought yeah i really like sort
of like uh this slide i think it has a
good i think it summarized pretty well
like um the word how you how your
individual ai and humans work together
in your current works
um and i guess do you
um expect i guess in in as you get into
more complex media like in the ar vr
space or some other spaces do you
imagine like ai take a larger role or
take a different kind of road than like
you know just the low-level
interpretation or like the nlp
extracting semantics um that kind of
tasks yeah that's a great question so
one thing i think about um especially ar
is that it's uh really dynamic and sort
of unknown what context you'll be sort
of accessing the information in right so
if i create you know maybe a a ar art
installation in a certain place and i
hope to see it in a new context it will
interact with that physical environment
differently and as an author i might or
might not know ahead of time um what
that will be and so i think yeah i think
you're right that there will be some
level of perhaps higher semantic
knowledge that um ai tools have to have
but i do think that's a really
interesting authoring question of how do
you give people access to authoring
information when it might change and the
real time interpretation will rely on
sort of what happens in terms of the
prediction quality and
what and new unknowns that you might not
have expected before
yeah great yeah i think i think it's
really exciting space to explore too
thank you thanks for the question
great
um i think it's also a similar question
to the last one um are there any
particular accessibility challenges for
ar content that are more difficult to
deal with in videos is there a chance
right now that the technology is still
not widely used to
intervene to improve accessibility oh i
think we definitely need to interview to
improve accessibility like i ideally it
would have been
you know even even earlier in the
process and i think that's the
opportunity we have right now is like
when we design
whatever the next ar is uh that we we
have this early in the process as well
but i do think that um so one thing that
makes ar particularly uh challenging and
i sort of briefly mentioned this is uh
the
i would say
summarization becomes a hard thing again
so just like video physical scenes are
going to have a lot of information so if
you're interacting with uh digital
content in a physical scene i think
picking what
of that physical content to describe to
you and what will be important in terms
of your interaction with the ar content
will have to um really be carefully
considered and i think it will be a
really challenging and fun problem to
work on um just because there are so
many things you could possibly describe
in the scene
knowing what's the most interesting um
to describe i think i think will be
quite challenging and i have worked
collaboratively on a project uh about
that led by uh
jalen at university of michigan and um
and we really just like scratched the
surface of what's of what's possible but
i i think that there's lots of room
for both technical research and
interaction research in that area
great
um
i think uh
we are getting to the end here so um i
wanted to say thank you
amy for a fantastic talk it's great to
hear about all this uh recent work